first story that we got for all y'all
Jimmy Fallon apologizes for resurfaced
blackface mm SNL skit
my first instinct and my first thought
is why and who cares Jimmy found is
basically apologizing for being comedian
which he should have done a long time
ago but fine
they say Jimmy Fallon apologized on
Tuesday after a Saturday Night Live skit
that aired 20 years ago resurfaced
featuring him appearing in blackface to
impersonate fellow former SNL cast
member Chris Rock the video made the
rounds on social media over Memorial Day
holiday weekend sending the hashtag
Jimmy Fallon his over party trending by
Tuesday morning
Fallon now the host of NBC's The Tonight
Show took to Twitter to apologize for
the skit calling his impersonation of
rock while in blackface a terrible
decision an unquestionably offensive
decision yet one that no one cared about
for 20 years and certainly no one cares
about now they're just pretending and
you know what if if you want to
apologize because you're on SNL and
every single person on SNL was okay with
it and went along with it
fine how about the rest of them come on
apologize to have a Lorne Michaels and
NBC and all of those people come out
apologize bro are we gonna have like
we're gonna have to get like the estates
of old comedians and the 20s oh come on
apologize I can't believe the jokes they
made back then that's the number one
requirement for being a Karen you have
to be offended for other people I'm
offended that you did something that'll
offend someone else so I'm fighting for
all those people I don't know any of
them but I'm gonna fight shut up it's
like they were sick of it they want to
enforce rules it's what it is yeah I
want some power it doesn't matter what
the rule is it's like I'm gonna tell you
what you're supposed to do you know
here's what they say while the full
sketch is not available on NBC's online
platforms a portion of it was uploaded
to YouTube on in early February 2019
MBC news cancelled megyn kelly today in
the wake of the morning host the morning
hosts on-air Halloween blackface defense
it wasn't even a defense megyn kelly on
NBC first of all that was a disaster
they hiring megan kelly was this one of
the stupidest things they could have
done she says something like people put
makeup on Halloween all the time like
why why is it offensive and everybody
was like that on the show they were like
well it is for these reasons she goes
huh
and that was it she was fired she went
huh thank God for it she she asked why
it was offensive
why was she said I don't understand you
know people you know dress up all the
time was why is it offensive
so she was simply asking she was just
ignorant she had no idea yeah and they
how do I become unag nur n't tho you ask
questions and get enlightened by people
that's why this is why I think you see
things like walk away nobody wants to be
associated with these people they're
unforgiving zealots yep but it's like
you man it really is this like dystopian
nightmare 1984 style thing it's like I
don't know if you've ever seen that skit
with who's that guy from Portlandia ya
know blue paint I don't know his name
but like the main actor he's got that
skit where he's a dictator and he's like
you know in Parks and Rec is that it
wasn't you know the skit I think so he's
from some South American country and
he's yeah your town is very small we
have much bigger towns and you you you
you slice the chicken rung straight to
jail yeah you you undercook the chicken
jail
you overcook the chicken jail he goes
believe it or not get yeah yeah yeah
that's exactly it
it's like you're walking down the street
and you're eating an ice cream in a drip
hits the ground it's like slow motion as
it falls and you're like hmm
and then splatters and alson all the
Karan's go and you look up and you're
surrounded by parents and they're all
like pointing at you and Jerry's Canada
and the Jerry's huddling scared and
you're like do something was like please
please I feel like Jerry is the weak
willed version of the male Karen right
but I don't know if it encompasses the
full male Karen identity he's a male
what is a male Karen we the guy from the
guy from Central Park today
he started the Karen name he was like
Karen Karen and she was like oh well
I'll raise you by caring more yeah and
it was truly Karen Karen intensifying it
was like exactly that can we just call
it like it like Karen ISM can it can we
make it like a functioning ideology
I just well let's let's let's let's
we'll keep it to be found for now
because we're gonna we're gonna jump
into that for sure yeah cuz we gotta
talk about Robert Downey jr. alright
yeah and like what is or is it offensive
because every so often some new young
Karen up-and-coming Karen Desai sees the
movie or or sees an old tweet and tweets
it out like how are we not canceling
this person and it's like oh my gosh
seriously it happened like a couple
weeks ago Robert Downey jr. was trending
I'm like oh great what's going on and
then sure enough half actually I'd say
about 90% of the tweets we're making fun
of the original tweet like look at this
another person that is a social justice
warrior trying to bring Robert Downey
jr. down it's like wow it reminds me of
South Park when they started the whole
PC cycle for the like the latest seasons
okay there's like an old guy knows all
looks like political correctness is back
again and they're like how long you
think it'll last it's like about six
seven years because it comes it was in
the 90s it comes and goes in waves
there's a cometh moral authoritarian
that comes more moral authoritarianism
but what's really funny about these
young people is it's like their first
foray into society it's like you're a
little kid and you're in school and
you're not really doing anything you
know it's like you're playing with
action figures listen to you know doing
tic TOCs or whatever it is the kids
these days are doing and then you get
older now you're on the internet and now
you're 14 15 and you're actually on
Twitter with a bunch of 40 year olds and
you're basically being told as your
first entry like into adulthood all we
do all day is form swarms to target
people over perceived slights and
destroy them and destroy their lives and
so they're like this is what I'm
supposed to do right so then all
suddenly Robert Downey jr. and they're
like wait a minute I thought we were
supposed to go and swarm people and
destroy them what about this guy and the
older ones like whoa whoa whoa not
Robert and you even got young people who
are like fans of you know Marvel who are
like oh man what about this one right
here let me let me let me pull this
story Millennials called canceled wait
what is this mechanic money was called
cancel to robert downey jr after
discovering his role in Tropic Thunder
this is from May 2020 so this is exactly
the one you saw
I don't know this sources play crazy
game so I just jumped back to Robert
Downey jr. actually opening up about his
use of blackface and Tropic Thunder from
January
apparently it comes up all the time I'm
sure it does yeah look at this like it's
actually one of the best performances in
it's not it's not even really here's the
thing about blackface when they used to
do actual blackface back in the day it
was purposefully insightful and like
meant to be exaggerated in derogatory
the way they'll put the makeup on their
mouths right and they would wear gloves
it was like purposefully insulting and
attacking and mocking if somebody's
impersonating someone else often that's
become blackface and now there was like
some woman I think like on the view or
something she put on bronzer in the 70s
and then people saw the photo and
they're like that's blackface it's like
no Matt it's just becoming like it's
just not but now it is and it's you know
you're gonna want one day you're gonna
put out you're gonna you're gonna go
tanning and they're gonna be like oh
you're putting on tan face or whatever
well who did who did he play he played
Chris Tucker or which Chris Rock Chris
Rock yeah did Chris Rock get upset
tonight that didn't seem like he did
it's like Chris Rock is he's pretty
famous he's a funny he's hilarious
actually he's many of his movies have
made me laugh and it's like so so Jimmy
Fallon was was just pretending to be a
great comedian can we do can we say that
instead it's like no no no no it's
racist I think it's a racist thing I
think people are bored you know it's
like is that what it is it's just
boredom yeah I think so social justice
boredom because think about what would
be hey look look it's like the worst I
grew up skateboarding right okay I got
no time for this right we got to go and
get dem kickflips
so we wake up in the morning and I'd be
like what's on the agenda for agenda for
today and I wit the Internet we'd go on
the internet we didn't have canceled
culture for the most part but for me
it's like though I don't care if someone
posted some dumb video I'd be like you
see that guy did that video things like
oh yeah whatever
hey man you want to go to that stair set
yeah remember that guy the Cubs field
who tried to catch that ball yeah you
already know what I'm talking about I
did even I mean I'm from Chicago it was
like it was the catch or the lack of
catch and he did catch it though didn't
he I think he did and he stopped Moises
Alou at
yeah and then supposedly that was the
reason they didn't go to the playoffs
it's like whatever downside like that
was as close as I think we got to cancel
culture like but no one still cared like
he got threats he got escorted out out
of the stadium cuz I was on I think I
was I was on Friendster at the time
friends - friends - Wow yeah did you
member Friendster did you have a friend
stir I I did I had a live journal and a
you journal and then there was what was
that one of the hot or not or something
I have no idea and then the first like
actual social media I guess technically
the journals were the first social
meeting that we had Friendster than
MySpace than Facebook yeah and there
were some weird ones in between like
little one offs and stuff I kinda just
disappeared but none of us cared about
what anyone else was posting you go to
someone's MySpace page to be a little
trash and like weird HTML code and like
music and glitter would be sprinkling
everywhere yeah and they would post
offensive things and nobody would say
anything it was no one cared like wow
it's like where did all this come from
Karen's Karen's our board
Karen Karen's be on the internet now you
know thinking about it it's interesting
when I was told when I was at fusion
right so if those not familiar fusion
was a joint venture between ABC News and
Univision
they said women share the most so I
asked him like why are we doing this
kind of content and I was told by
somebody the the angry women are the
most likely to share stuff so if you
want to get content that gets the most
traffic in the most views it's awful
woman yes
so Karen's perpetuate Karen's that's
what I was saying the other day about
how they manipulated the algorithm and
now created social justice yeah yeah
it's because they were specifically
targeting middle-aged women for sure
like literally they said mothers who are
angry share more than anyone else so in
that sense mainstream media has actually
been telling Karen's for years that
they're correct yep yep yeah and then
letting them loose yeah it's like dude
you want it you want to find some blame
basically BuzzFeed and Huffington Post
and Vox have had like a giant you know
cage full of ravenous Karen's and the
the Karen barons were standing atop
Stadium and they pulled the you know
the rope or whatever and it lifts up the
gate and all the Karen start running out
my back and then we're all running and
now they've unleashed all the Karen's on
everybody
Karen Barron i I can't unhear that Karen
there that's fantastic I feel like it's
like the the highest order a shelah of
Karen like all Karen's aspire to be the
Karen Barron kind of it's the dark
conspiracy behind the carrot it's more
like I would say it's more akin to a mad
scientist to genetically engineering
Karen's in a lab okay so it's like you
you have a regular middle-aged mom and
she like she walks in and the kids are
playing in the back and she's like I'm
gonna make some sandwiches for ya what
do you want the peanut butter and jelly
oh don't you know that's not good for
you to play there in the mud like that
and then she walks inside and she's
going when she's butter in the bread and
then her phone Boop's and she goes oh
what's this someone sending me a text
message and she opens it up and it's
some police brutality video from now
this and then all sudden her hair just
goes like makes the shape and just like
get the haircut huh yeah okay that makes
sense
yep the hair just like forms into that
weird what does that haircut even called
that's a short it's a Karen it's called
the carrots okay yeah Karen cut yeah
Karen cut and then like her care changes
and the inner son walks in he's like mom
are you okay and she goes and she like
runs out and she's like starts pointing
at people put your dog on a leash you
you made a jump 20 years ago yep and
then that's where we are today
yeah and then they form online
communities and then they're sitting in
their keyboards you know they're bored
it's actually you know it no but but to
be honest like it's funny we're totally
talking about someone doing blackface 20
years ago and we keep getting into the
Karen conversation because it but I know
I know they know it's the same it's all
kind of animation of the same thing
that's been going on but I was reading a
story about trolls right our Karen's
they're all Karen's there was a story
about trolls and like I think was in the
UK they tracked down the trolls they
like okay somebody sent a nasty comment
to him and so they like take a car and
they go drive out to milnor and they go
to the guy's house and knock on the door
and they're like are you you know
Angus McCloud 53 okay the guys
like yeah he's like you send a message
to me saying this that and that's why
would you do it and the guys like oh I
don't know I just you know I was on the
internet I don't really know yeah so I
read reading this story I look shaming
basically yeah but it's it's it's like
why do people want to join a mob and
jump and jump around and do the same
thing as everybody else it's like a
survival mechanism I guess because
everyone wants to be a part of something
that's it we're humans that's that's
what we do and the way society is built
we put we get our own little cubicle
boxes that we live in we're by ourselves
a lot of people don't find others aren't
aren't lucky to find someone else that
makes them happy so then they become
miserable they go on the internet they
meet with all the other miserable people
and then those people create the Karen
ISM that we have today that's it man
people want connection they want to be
connected so me yelling at you and
having any out anyone else go yeah I
agree with that guy yelling at this dude
I'm gonna yell at him too like boom all
of a sudden you know what I wonder have
a group I think it's Laura tribe really
tribalism right in in the real world we
have Karen herd immunity because if you
have if you have a neighborhood let's
say you have like a community group or
whatever maybe it's a church or
something and you have a hundred people
and that for every one hundred person
let's say there are you know for every
for every 50 people you get a Karen okay
if you have a hundred people and you
have to Karen's when that one Karen
steps out of line the group isn't in
line with the Karen Inge they push back
in the Karen recoils and oh you know I
don't wanna offend the group right okay
so you get one Karen in this you know to
Karen's in a group of 101 Karen speaks
up and shuts you know basically
complaining but the people all around
her or like stop complaining stop you're
rocking the boat and so the Karen backs
down good but when the Karen's can go on
the internet and he's surrounded by
Karen's and now there's no more hyouta
minute hurt herd immunity because
they're surrounded by Karen's mmm-hmm
they you know basically you know by by
our powers combined we become Captain
Karen and all of that Karen ism is now
unfettered and on you know unrestrained
and just takes it concentrated force
emerges and then it's like it reminds me
of you know that game was it called like
Kim Mari or whatever I don't know it's
like the little guy and he like rolls
the ball or something was like
called Katamari you know I'm talking you
referenced hood before that like gathers
junk
yeah it's getting bigger and yeah I've
never played it but we've talked about
it long time in the Karen starts the
snowball you know people get sucked into
it
mmm you got to resist cuz for me I I
don't know man
if I if I saw a large crowd of people
and they were all waving pitchforks and
screamin I'd get away from them yep why
would you want to be in that you know I
don't know I was in at a trump rally in
San Jose and this is where was like I
had this viral video clip where a guy
walks up behind the Trump supporter and
smacks him the back of that with what's
like a bag of something they said was a
bag of rocks and I remember being there
it was nuts they were attacking people
this one dude who was clearly not a
trump support got punched in the mouth
like in the lower jaw and his mouth's
bleeding and it's because he was in one
of these mops no one knew what was going
on no one knew what they were doing or
why they were doing it all they knew is
that when one person started running
towards another person the whole mob
would go after without stomping and
punching and beating the person and
that's what I see when I see these these
online things like Oh Jimmy foo like use
a joke that's what it is you know you
know it's like nobody nobody actually
cares they just don't they just do their
I don't know man people have fun running
with a crowd of people romping and
stomping I guess but he apologized so he
obviously he admitted that he did
something wrong so he did something
wrong fire him then yeah sure
Jimmy Fallon you messed up because I
don't think you did anything wrong but
by you giving in to these Karen's and
saying I'm sorry that I was a comedian
and I'm I thought or actually no I did
something that was funny 20 years ago
here we are in 2020 you're apologizing
for it's like dude that's on you you
know what man who let the Karan's win
did you see Ellen make that joke about
the lockdown where she was like it feels
like I'm in prison because everyone's
wearing the same clothes yeah or she's
like I'm wearing the same clothes
everyone round me everywhere I'm he's
gay or whatever right mad people started
to get upset and she's like okay I
thought it was a dumb joke
sure it was yeah it was a bad joke Joe
Joe Rogan thought it was hilarious I
mean there's because it was still a joke
right there's some people out there that
like bad jokes and we're trolli jokes
you know what man comedy is not allowed
just just none of it
it seems like now it is if I'll put it
this way if you're a Ricky Gervais if
you're Dave Chappelle if you're Kevin
Hart if you're Joe Rogan Who am I
missing
who's a good one bill burr bill burr is
pretty good he's great yeah you're
allowed to be a comedian all of you guys
you have my permission if you're Jimmy
Fallon or anyone or Alan or anybody else
we'll actually did Alan apologize for
that I have no idea if you're any one of
these comedians who's gonna apologize
could you told a joke and like people
got angry you do not have my permission
to be a comedian I'm kidding it's not
like you need it as a joke I'm just
saying like why be a comedian if you're
like let me tell a joke and then a day
later it's like you're fired
right just just stop just just give up
that's your audience is insane they
don't want jokes they want how do you
even tell these jokes how can you be a
comedian with that thin of skin
comedians say brutal things and they get
ridiculed and they get laughed at and
people it's either you love him or hate
him but the best comedians don't care
about anyone that hates them and focus
on the people that like him and then
that spreads and then they get better at
being a comedian and then they get more
well-known like look at Ricky Gervais he
says the craziest stuff to all like he
was at the Oscars that he bombed him he
dropped bombs on all those people he was
dropping fire and it was hilarious and
they were sweating they were looking
around I like are we supposed to be
really upset right now yeah are we are
we getting this happen and he's like I
don't care yeah and that's it right
there he just doesn't care and that's
like Bravo Ricky you're the best
seriously yeah I need that we need that
in comedy right now Jimmy Fallon you are
ruining it for more comedians this is
just it's just one more domino falling
down I mean good riddance first Iram
fire the gas he doesn't deserve to have
a job if he's scared like a joke 20
years ago and now people are offended by
it but it's not even about Jimmy Fallon
it's him letting them win now right so
they're like all Karen's around the
world are rejoicing right now we
cancelled another one everyone woo
that's actually it's a funny thing that
he had to apologize in the New York
Times wrote an Barry Weiss for the air
time sort of pinyon piece did an
interview with Joe Rogan about his sale
to Spotify and he basically said you
know it was alluding to the fact that
you can't be cancelled
if you work for yourself like ooh
if you said something offensive what are
they gonna do was gonna call me be like
Tim Adam something offends on ya know he
was sitting right next to me right
what he didn't do about it yeah and so
for him jota's got apologized running it
says yo yeah it's his it's his room yep
but Jimmy works for somebody else
exactly and they're scared
he wasn't apologizing they probably
called him up and said apologize right
now they probably have control of his
Twitter account and they they were alone
maybe Jimmy wakes up one day looks at
his phone so I apologize boys back to
Selena I don't think it's that bad
I think he did it I think he apologized
yeah sure his because I'm really read
his I mean you could just see his
personality he wants to make everybody
happy that's just stupid his thing
that's his that's his personality you
know he just
you can tell every time I've ever seen
him talk talked about anyone talked to
anyone he just wants to make everyone
happy so if anyone's offense offended by
something he's done that's why he's
apologizing I see it I get it Jimmy
you're you're a nice guy that's what it
is
these people don't actually care I know
I don't care what Jimmy does and that's
why he's apologizing but you're also
giving them a victory and making it
worse for the future of when they come
after the next comedian who is doing
something less offensive you know it
kind of reminds me of a kid like walking
into the moms are women going mom mom
mom mom
yeah when she's finally like what do you
want who's he and he runs away yeah like
the Stewie things she finally goes what
what do you want goes yeah and he just
runs off like he did want anything he
just want to get a rise out of you so
here's Jimmy like I'm so sorry I did
this I made a joke 20 years ago it was
offensive and and these people are just
sitting there like oh who do we take now
it's like I don't know you find somebody
all right how about Robert Downey jr.
hmm been there done that we tried it
didn't work yeah we'll try every couple
years but it never it never works it's
confusing to them they'll like is that a
target well no not Robert we like why is
that no that's not even it it's not even
because people like Robert Downey jr.
it's cuz he was every single tweet I
mean a lot of people a lot of tweets
were from black folks that were saying
we know it was a it was making fun of
white people in blackface right right
that's what little movie was about all
of them were like I never I didn't see
one you know African
American person that was upset about it
they were all everyone was making fun of
this young white girl it was she was so
like it was vividly a like a I don't
know 20 year old white person that was
like pissed off it's like why are you
mad who are you mad for yeah Oh your
mother's a Karen right yeah you've
inherited the cat and that's that's
another issue is they're teaching their
kids you see that that video the the
girl crying because someone flipped her
off yeah and her mom stormed out go find
the person it was like you're teaching
that's what you're teaching your kids
you know it's kind of nice paradoxical
and kind of ironic is that a lot of
these sjws are upper class white people
yeah and they're also the Karen's yeah
like it's all carrying so exactly they
actually proved themselves kind of right
about white people there that you're
right it's true it's you it's terrible
because it's like as a white person I'm
offended at Karen carries the same name
they offend me yeah that they're racist
they're they're like prolonging the
racism in this world it's like god
that's stop thanks for checking out this
clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do
the show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you